- [Female Voice] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(lively music)
- Welcome to A Conversation
With History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Stephen S. Cohen
who is professor in the Graduate School,
the University of California at Berkeley
and he's also co-director
of the Berkeley Roundtable
on the International
Economy also at Berkeley.
He's a senior fellow at
the New America Foundation
in Washington and he's just
written with Brad DeLong,
The End of Influence, What
Happens When Other Countries
Have The Money.
Steve, welcome to our program.
- Good to be here with you, Harry.
- Where were you born and raised?
- New York.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Oh my god, that's a hard question,
you told me you guys didn't
play with easy questions.
They kind of applauded if you
were reasonable and realistic,
and didn't think,
or weren't all that
impressed if you could cite
the great religious authorities.
- And was there a lot of
discussion about politics
and the economy around the dinner table
or did that come later?
- That came later.
- And what got you interested
in pursuing degrees in the
field of politics and economics?
- I was an undergraduate.
- [Harry] Where did you do your undergrad?
- Williams College.
- [Harry] Aha.
- For young boys of
good family at the time.
They've subsequently never (mumbles)
And I was a major in political
science and economics
and I couldn't tell 'em,
I didn't know where one
ended and the other began.
I've had a lifelong difficulty.
Is this economics? Is this politics?
So I kind of did both.
- And then from there, you
went on to graduate school and?
- Oh, there was a little interruption.
I was too early as an undergraduate editor
of the college magazine.
The Dean called me into
his office, and said,
"I'm giving you a choice.
"A, you're out of here
today, I'm throwing you out.
"Or B, you stop editing that thing
"and go take a junior year abroad."
And I said Paris, he said, "Done."
- And what was he objecting
to, a particular article?
- [Stephen] Oh, yes.
- Or a general tone of...
- First it was the tone and then there was
a particular piece.
Looking back it was kind of obnoxious.
It was about some poor guy there
who taught a course on
religion and sex and love
in the Bible among other things,
and was up to be president
of a small college nearby.
So I wrote a little limerick.
- I see, so it was off to Paris.
- Jointly signed with the daughter
of the chairman of the board
of trustees of that College
who's an undergraduate
at Smith at the time.
For that, you should be tossed.
I mean it was just awful.
- I see, so do you get more discipline
in Paris or was it rather you were exposed
to the culture and stayed with it--
- I don't think it was
more about discipline
and so much as exposure to the world.
And of all places to
think about an economy,
France, never accepted
the kind of economics
we mainstream here.
The difference in the
government and the...
didn't make sense to anybody,
that the government was the referee.
No, the government is
the partner of everything
and every one.
The state not the government.
- Did that experience give you a focus
so that you now really
kind of have a sense
of what you wanted to do--
- Well, it didn't give me any focus,
I really had a great time.
So much to see and do and learn,
how to learn about eating,
how to learn about art,
it was just endless.
And when I got back, this
one professor called me,
"And what was your project?"
I thought, (blabbers).
I started looking at
French economic planning.
- [Harry] I see.
- So he said very good, write
a paper about it so I did.
And then I went off to graduate school.
First I applied to law school a few times.
And the Harvard Law
School has that catalog,
the Facebook, the pictures
of the incoming class.
If you look under Cohen,
not only comes Steve Cohen
'cause a few of it, there's
one photo missing, that was me.
- I see, so you got
accepted but didn't go.
- I actually wrote a stupid letter,
still wise guy kid.
I looked upon entering
the Harvard Law School
as a symbol of my own
total defeat in life.
- I see, I see.
And they didn't take
kindly to that, I guess.
- Oh, they care a lot.
I'm sure they were not in
the least bit disturbed.
'Cause I applied the year after
and they admitted me again,
I didn't go again. (laughs)
And then I went to the London School.
- And focusing on?
Politics and the--
- I did it.
And they had a, you
might call it a program
where you could do both.
So I did and I ended up doing a thesis on?
- French planning.
- French economic planning, you see?
The littlest, they stick you.
- What was it, just to
be clear about this,
what was it that led to this focus?
You think that experience,
junior year abroad
and then you found this whole interface
between the two realms very significant?
- It sounds so noble.
It was that experience and
the need, that afternoon,
to have a subject for that professor
in half an hour.
There I had a, so I kept going.
And that was, in those
days a thesis at LSE was,
the idea was you'd write a book.
Not an article or two articles
that shows you can play,
they do all the necessary
tricks, he wrote a book.
So I wrote this book and it
came out at Harvard Press,
called Modern Capitalist
Planning, something like that.
- I actually have it,
Modern Capitalist Planning,
The French Model, right.
What did you learn in
the writing of that book
and the research it entail?
I mean did it raise you to a new level
in seeing this interface?
- First it was all about the interface.
The state, business, the economy.
And where it's all seen as one.
And I started looking around the world
and the country's making
important changes, rapid growth,
changes where they go, Japan.
And you see the enormous role of policy
of the actions of the state in steering it
and enabling it.
And that in a funny way set me up
for an understanding of Japan.
When, they used to be those big arguments.
There was no argument
Japan was doing well.
- This would be now in the 80s--
- No, the 70s and the 80s, 70s and 80s.
Japan was definitely doing well,
there was no question, fabulously.
And there was a whole, I think a majority
of American economists saying,
well, the state is too involved,
they should get out of everything.
And no one in Japan thought
this made any sense whatsoever.
Makes no sense.
And it was easier for me to understand
what the Japanese thought they were doing
'cause I thought of it in French,
as opposed to thinking
of it in Anglo-Saxon
as the French would call it.
That kind of carried through
in most things I have done.
- Now this raises an interesting question
because what we've learned
here is that you wound up
going abroad to see this connection,
and that turned you in essence
into a political economist,
I guess one would say,
which is not something
that grows naturally in
the American environment.
- And now you find us under
glass in a few museums.
We don't do that.
- Well, you're brought
out from under the glass
when there's a crisis in
the system which leads us
kind of a--
- And we have crises
rather frequently nowadays.
- Now, so let's say that the students
want to figure out how to
develop the skills to do this.
How do you prepare?
What is it you have to learn
in the way of a skill set
to do political economics well?
- You have to first
learn to be marginalized.
- (laughs) So live with being an outsider?
- Normal career paths closed.
No kidding around, it's a
closed shop in economics really.
You don't do it.
If you can't make an econometric
model, you can't utter it.
And you can make very
powerful econometrics models
at the expense of what you talk about.
Has to be small and it's
built on a set of assumptions.
- So, and this is something
I wanted to talk about it,
is in comparing what you
do to what an economist
and the economics profession,
you're saying there's a kind
of narrowness of the focus,
an awe at the elegance of the theory
which may or may not relate
to what's actually going on
in the real world.
- Oh, definitely.
In fact I don't believe
as a requirement for a PhD
in most of the top economics departments.
You were asked to know
anything about economic,
the history of economic thought,
or about economic history.
What had had happened out there and...
I think that's an egregious loss.
- And also politics, right?
I mean it isn't there--
- [Stephen] They don't do politics.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The assumption...
- So, in a way, a flaw here is that,
there is a disconnect which
leads to a lack of understanding
of kind of the institutional setting,
the politics of the setting
in which a particular
paradigm is embraced?
- Yeah, or viewed in another way.
As an economist, there's a trade off.
For the power of your analysis,
you sacrifice its relevance
and its range.
And sometimes that comes
around to bite you badly.
- And I think we've already
learned from you that,
in your particular case,
your analysis of France
contributed to the power
of your analysis of Japan
when that became an important issue,
that is the rise of the Japanese economy.
So what I'm hearing you
say is comparative studies
become very important that
is comparing case studies.
- It absolutely helps to know something
about what's going on over there,
especially when they interact.
- Now, you were a
co-founder and a co-director
of the Berkeley Roundtable on
the International economy--
- [Stephen] BRIE, like the cheese.
- BRIE, like the cheese, of course,
it would have to be because
of that junior year.
That was what--
- [Stephen] And most of those
years as a grad student also.
- Right, so what then,
and talk a little about
that group here at Berkeley,
because it became important for the campus
and internationally and sort
of understanding the trends
and the world where political
economy was really important
as we became less competitive
and the rest of the world
became or some parts of it
became more competitive.
- That's another one of these things.
Life's about a certain
nigh of the accidental.
I had spent two years
in New York previously,
sabbatical and some other I
don't remember what, fellowship.
Most of it I spent hanging around
the Institute for Humanities at NYU.
Where they gave me this marvelous office
and there were some interesting people.
- Great, did you read a
lot of novels or what...
- The novels were the nice part of it.
Just studies of the
studies that criticized
the studies of the novels were
a little, not my favorite.
But I came back.
When I got back, what am I gonna do?
And it's seeing, what do we have here?
The great outdoors.
- [Harry] California and me.
- Yeah, I'm not too good at that.
Then there was strange and
exotic sexual practices
at the time.
I lucked out with an absolutely
lovely and beautiful wife.
I wasn't gonna be good at it anyway.
So that left technology,
which I knew nothing.
- It was fun to learn a little
and semiconductors go into
everything, everything.
So all of a sudden, if
you follow the chip,
you get wherever you want to go.
And this was around 1982.
So I met up with John Zysman
in political science here
and very shortly thereafter
with Laura Tyson in economics,
said let's work together
So we didn't found an institute,
we said let's actually work together.
We get some outside
dough, and we co-run it,
we don't need a great stamp of
approval from the bureaucracy
we just cooperate which
is unusual on a campus.
Exceedingly so.
And that has held for all these
25 years and change, more.
And we started, what was really going on
was the Japanese challenge
to the United States
in advanced technology as
well as in manufacturing.
So out of that came an early
book, I did with John Zysman
called Manufacturing Matters,
where we argued it is a poor idea
for a great big nation, not for
a little specialized place,
Luxembourg, London, for a big,
to lose its advantages in manufacturing.
- And that was kind of the
beginning of this cycle
where we were doing less
and less manufacturing,
which actually becomes
an important element
in your new book.
- Yeah, and we, one of the keys was
the Japanese firms were terrific.
(mumbles) it was a heavy role
for Japanese government pushing this.
And our argument was, this
is the way it's being played
so maybe we oughta play it
intelligently in these terms.
We didn't.
- The United States, you mean? Yeah.
Let's now move to your book
because a lot of these themes
we've been talking about
come together here.
Let me show it one more time.
The End of Influence, What
Happens When Other Countries
Have The Money?
So why did you and Brad
DeLong write this book?
- Well, again it started less delivery.
I find much of my life is,
lacking in a certain amount
of strategic planning,
that we were going to do a
piece on sovereign wealth funds.
The rise of these enormous tills.
- [Harry] Pots of money.
- Huge.
- That are controlled, which you explain--
- [Stephen] By the government.
- Right.
- Directly or indirectly,
but government controlled
large amounts of money.
It's a little different than what had
been previously the case.
And the model for all of these has always
been multi-exemplary Norway.
Norway good.
Norway is Kuwait done right.
- Because Norway had oil--
- Oil money piling up, and
they learned something.
If you just dished it out
to everyone in Norway.
you're gonna have an inflation,
you were gonna make all your,
your currency would go way up,
all your normal business
would be destroyed
in terms of competitive,
and you have a mess.
This used to be called the Dutch disease.
- Because the Dutch had
gone through this experience
in the '60, they had some oil,
they generated a lot of money
and they blew it all away.
- It did them no good, the opposite.
So the Norwegians simply
said, we're putting it all
in a bank account offshore.
Because you bring it onshore, it raises it
and we'll live on the interest.
- And the money is in another currency,
the dollar in this case?
- It's invested abroad,
in other currencies.
Overwhelmingly, large portion
in dollars and all over.
And they invested the way
the California retirement system does.
They don't own more than
1% of what they invest in.
They have some political things.
No bomb makers, I think
no cigarette maker,
they're good, good.
- [Harry] Good Scandinavian--
- Good, good, good Norway.
Now if all the investment
funds were like this,
it'd be not at all,
certainly not even a problem,
not even a question, they're not.
You have a very large Russian,
sovereign wealth fund.
- [Harry] From oil also?
- Yeah, yeah, from oil.
Well, there are two sources of these.
There's the mineral, the
oil which are a bunch
of the Persian Gulf and oil countries,
and Russia in a big way.
And then there are the
Chinese manufacturers,
the Asian manufacturers, exemplary China.
Which has north of $2,000 billion dollars.
- [Harry] In dollars?
- Yeah, say about that, north
of two trillion in dollars
sitting there in various tills.
It's not necessarily
a sovereign world fund
but under direct and
indirect government control.
How do you use it?
Well, if you were the Chinese government,
you'd try and use it strategically.
I mean one thing is you
just put it out there
and earn a return and
people line for index funds.
In others you say, well
our mission here on earth
is to advance the Chinese economy.
Well, we got this enormous tool here,
what do we do with it?
Well, what we need, we
could use some technology.
Well, this may help us get it.
And so we were raising
some of these questions.
Ooh, come to think of it,
it might be political,
if that President of the United
States, whatever his name is
makes no difference, starts doing things
that we don't like, that
hurt us, that irk us.
What if the limousine that
brings the Chinese bankers
to New York to buy the US
debt every Thursday morning,
has a flat tire?
In fact, what if we announced in advance
we're going to have a
flat tire and not show?
That might send the market
town a thousand points.
That president, maybe
he has to think about us
before opening his big mouth.
This is a change, is this not a change?
- So in essence, what came about
as the sovereign funds
developed especially
in the case of the Chinese,
was really a change in the power balance
between the two countries
beginning in the economic realm.
And this is a major
unexpected disturbance,
if you buy into what you
call the neoliberal view
of the world, which was the doctrine,
the policy that the
United States had embraced
several decades ago.
So the book moves toward a look,
essentially it's the epitaph
of the neoliberal paradigm
for domestic policy in the United States,
because that policy produced
this very great disturbance
which we'll talk about again in a minute,
the sovereign funds.
- Several other big disturbances.
Yes, I think it has been
pretty unfortunate for America.
- So what is the neoliberal paradigm?
- That's really simple.
Leave it to the market.
Get the fat, stupid bureaucratic
hands of the state out.
Deregulate.
And play this out.
And everything will spin
around and work out fine.
Now, there are a lot
of problems with this,
sometimes it doesn't, that's
called macroeconomics gains.
But also, what if the other
guys are not doing it?
They may even make-believe,
which I don't believe
for a minute that this
is the best way to do it
for a country.
But what about the other countries?
So if you were playing touch football,
and the other guy's got a
helmet and shoulder pads,
maybe this is not a good idea.
There is a strategic element
and that's sometimes absent
in such thinking.
A whole bunch of things came together.
One was I start a long
argument in this book
that way income distribution.
The period I don't know 1947,
when the dust settled from the war
up into the mid 70s, the
American economy was doubled.
GDP per capita.
And the guy, the 50-yard line,
the guy in the exact
median income district,
he doubled also.
And the guy in the top
10%, he doubled also.
So we went with an
unchanging income district,
the ranks didn't change
for the great generation.
- So we maintain
prosperity, we move forward
from say the 30 years after World War II
and everybody was gaining together.
- Equally.
- Equally, yeah.
And that was the great American dream,
and we were gaining even bigger
than the numbers indicated
because you got television
and washing machines,
pricing deflators don't
explain what really,
like penicillin, I mean.
And that lowers the cost.
So this doesn't tell you how good it was.
So the next 25, 30 years--
- [Harry] Beginning say in about '74.
- By the mid 70s 'cause
I don't have the numbers
in front of me, I don't
want to get hung in that.
We grew a bit slower, but we grew.
I don't know, about
three-quarters increase
over the period till now-ish.
And roughly speaking, all
the gang went to the top 10%.
The middle gained way under 1% per year,
and the counting is not so clear.
These are not precise,
they pretend to be precise,
they try to be precise but it's hard.
So we had a real shift.
Then we also changed the
shape of the economy.
- So and now let me just
remind our audience,
we're walking you through the consequences
of the neoliberal paradigm
which dominated both political parties
and which was embraced by
both Reagan and Clinton
and the Bushes.
- Yeah, and another thing
that sort of happened
since say 1980-ish,
manufacturing as a
percentage of GDP looked
at what we produce.
Declined by about 6% of GDP.
6% of GDP is a big number.
It gets you one Pentagon,
the whole darn thing.
That's about, it gives you a
sense of size, one Pentagon.
And we offset it by increasing
the proportion of GDP
by exactly the same amount of finance,
insurance and real estate
transactions, the paperwork.
Complete reshaping of our economy.
We've reshaped our economy
many times in the past.
It was always led by government policy,
as is typically the case.
The great example was
the opening of the West,
the transcontinental railways
led by government policy
which was easy policy 'cause first,
big and good government
policy is always easy.
Because everyone kinda of agrees,
how you do it is where the
nastiness comes in, okay.
And it was easy because they
didn't have to vote any money,
had all that unlimited amounts of land
so we'll give you a checkerboard pattern.
This shaped the economy, the--
- In the 19th century and
into the 20th century.
- Big shaping, growth of railway, steel,
all the mass market tiers, Sears,
it sort of followed.
We get another round of this
after world war II, the suburbanization.
Made possible, enabled planned,
perhaps without knowing it
but doesn't matter.
Morgan insurance, the GI bill, the FHA,
the government guaranteed
loans and the highways.
The National Defense Highway Act
which ringed the cities
with suburban highways.
We used to have to call it,
in case the Russians wanted
to go from shopping
center to shopping center.
- And then finally, the big
defense budget, that is the--
- The great permanent defense budget,
and more recently, the
shift to allow finance
to really get out of the box and it did.
- So what you're suggesting is that,
as a political economist, you can see
that the embrace of a
paradigm was in a way
a kind of a statement of planning
which wasn't put out there
for everybody to see,
but the consequences were
it shaped our economy in the future.
- If you think about things this way,
you'll do things that way.
Well, if you're gonna
go do things that way,
we have someone here
that say, if you do this,
you're gonna get this kind of thing.
If you do that, you're gonna get that.
So we borrow all this money from China
the average American family goes deeper
and deeper into debt,
because this income is going nowhere
and we're consuming more and more.
All this goes through the banking system.
- So the banks are making a lot
of money on everybody's debt
as they go into debt?
- Sure.
One side, it's pretty straightforward.
The Chinese factory makes some stuff.
Walmart gets it, puts
it on their shelf, done.
- We are not making
that product presumably,
in theory, yeah.
- Or anymore.
Or less and less, or it's being squeezed.
And you're see it.
That is that 6% because
the manufacturing declined
by 6% of GDP on this
side of what we produce,
not on the side of what we consume.
That didn't change very much.
We still get the grotesque
number of T-shirts,
and the cars, the fuel.
It's just coming in,
so that didn't change.
It's not like manufacturing
went away out of the earth,
it went away geographically.
Now what we did with this borrowed money,
what we put in place of
the manufactured jobs
was our doing.
We didn't have to do that.
We could have put it into any number
of worthwhile endeavors.
Health, for--
- Or to energy technology.
- Yes for example.
We didn't.
- So, in looking at this,
what we embrace in a bipartisan way,
a view of what our policy should be
that decrees an unfettered market,
and I think you say in the
book a fettered government.
The government ties its hands
and Greenspan brings out the punchbowl,
and by that we mean, it's a free market
both globally and nationally.
And you're telling us in this book and now
that the consequences were
over time greater inequality,
if not a consequence it
followed along with this,
a bloating of the financial sector
without our sort of consciously
doing this and it being--
- Nobody took control and
said we're gonna have such--
- Yeah, right, but it,
and then the third thing was the helping,
pushing along, furthering
the Chinese emergence
as an economic superpower
because they became the place
where products were made
and to protect their own economy,
they save the money and
began loaning it to us
as we spent more than we made.
- In a way, it's more
of an intimate embrace
that nobody wants.
Let's take US and China.
We owe them two trillion box,
maybe even more.
Okay, they call up, they want it.
We say, "No problem, do you
want in $100 bills or 20s?
"We'll fill an aircraft carrier
with it and send it out."
So there's no way they
can get their money back.
There's no way we can pay it,
it's like 20,000 bucks per household.
So there we are, we're
stuck with each other.
They need us because
they built their economy
to be export-led.
Were they crazy to do this?
And they get this money they can't use?
Now, they could use it,
they could buy all their cars here,
but this would wreak hell on
their auto and steel industries
and so forth, they don't want to do that.
This was a little the way Keynes explained
the economic consequences
of the Versailles Treaty.
The French and British said the Germans
are going to pay us
back, and he said, how?
Do you want steel, you want cars?
No, no, no, no, no, no,
we want (blabbers).
Doesn't work, but were they crazy?
And I don't think so, I don't think so.
Their intention, their goal,
and I think they realize their goal
beyond their wildest dreams,
was to learn how to make things.
You had a nation of peasants,
really poor peasants.
I don't think Americans understand
how poor a poor peasant is.
Pull the rice, do you have electricity?
Probably not and so forth.
- So by exporting and protecting yourself
from a situation where
you're forced to devalue
your currency, you
continue to industrialize,
you're converting more and more
of these peasants into
workers working in the city,
you're producing more and more goods,
you're learning how to manufacture--
- You get to learn how to do it.
Learning in university, it's expensive.
Learning is expensive.
This was the machine, they
had a nation of peasants,
they couldn't produce large
amounts of consumer goods
for their own country, because
there was no one to buy it,
there was no buying power there.
And you know these dollars are probably,
they could be useful, they're
not altogether wasted.
So they got to get good
and therefore powerful at production.
- And under this formula,
they need to sell these
products and there,
and then we get the result
you already described,
namely they make all these dollars
but they want to keep
them far away so to speak,
and hence the development
of the enormous power
of their sovereign fund.
- That sort of thing, yeah.
So they have all this money and balances
and they got to do something with it.
And some of the things are obvious.
They'll buy a lot of,
what do you do with it?
Okay, they keep buying American
government Treasury bills,
Fannie Mae's, that's one of the
reason the government ran in
and said okay, we're covering Fannie Mae
because of China.
Another thing they will
necessarily do is buy American,
and companies around the world because,
did you get something for it?
Doubly, maybe you get
more than you just bought
that company for.
You may be able to bring
home what it does best,
and root that at home and
move up the technology
and competence ladder.
And you get power or viewed the other way,
America has had the money
for about 100 years.
And after the war certainly
we had all the money,
everybody owed us money.
Now we are the world's biggest debtor,
and there is no number two,
and there's no number three
and there's no number
four and no number six
and then you get Argentina,
and a few other basket cases.
We owe everybody tons, and some people
a really great tonnage.
Now we used to use the money.
- When we were making
in and had the money.
- We still think we do.
We haven't realized much of this.
We always used it for
the good of the world,
but it was we who defined
what was good for the world.
So when the French and
British, I think it was in 1956
sent some troops into Suez
to tell that fellow, Nasser,
straighten him out about the
Suez Canal and that properly,
Ickes, who no one never accused
of being a pinko, right?
Ickes' okay, said (clears throat)
he kind of hinted that
he might cough to hint
that they might hint to dink
the Sterling and the Franc
and on the spot out they came.
We had the money, we used it as a lever,
we used it to support
the electoral prospects
of various parties in Italy, let's say
against other parties in Italy
who we thought would be
less good for the maturation
of democracy and which I
think we were quite right.
We used it.
- And it also gave us soft
power, your suggesting--
- It was the basis of our soft power,
and we were the example to the world.
So we had this very
wonderful kind of soft power,
where people do like we do.
They kind of imitate our ways,
our institutions, our mannerisms
and you don't have to tell
them to, they want to.
And this is something
the English enjoy truly.
They came up with this
great story of the gentleman
who is a mixture of a medieval
knight, a Scottish miser,
this and that and okay.
And they invented these activities.
Sports, organized sports.
All of them, tennis, soccer,
all of them.
the whole idea of organizing
came out of England.
The whole way of being
and doing, dressing,
if you look at a photo
of the late 18th century,
the Court of Louisville.
They were dressed in glorious blue and red
and green silks, wigs and everybody was.
Then you got the shift where
England became unquestionably
the power and it was commercial England.
The whole world is suddenly
dressed in drab gray,
the same suit we still wear.
The collar goes up and down a
little, in and out a little,
we took some of the starch out but,
in every domain you see the power of this,
the ascendant, the dominant, the society.
Now the economy is the big engine of that
but this other stuff lasts.
Even after the reason
for it, you carry on.
So we have had an enormous
influence all around the world,
God save us all.
Young people have the body
language of American teenagers,
they listen to the...
- So, let's take this
analysis another step
as you do in the book, because
what you're really saying
is that our paradigm,
the neoliberal paradigm
led us to really change who we were
in an important respect.
But it also led to a change
in the balance of power
between states, and the creation
of the sovereign funds.
And I think the next step
in your analysis is to say,
well, wait a minute,
this is all coming about
and what is emerging is a different view
of the relation of the
state to the economy,
especially in these places
which are the holder
of the sovereign funds.
And you're raising a question about,
will they be able to
capture the innovation
and the ability to innovate
which comes with having money
and being able to buy companies,
to have foreign facilities
in your own country?
The next big question is,
how far will they be able to take that?
- I think you've got it,
I think that's an essential question.
Certainly, having the money helps.
You and I formed this clever startup
or investor comes from
some Chinese company,
maybe partnered with an
American private equity thing
but the Chinese company is borrowing
unbelievable amounts
of money from the bank
which itself is borrowing
unbelievable amounts of money
from the Chinese government.
So that same fund coming
through a few stops comes here,
they invest in our technology
and our investor says,
hey, we're going, go, go,
go, go, you need more money.
We could really do this well
if we move, keep you guys here,
if forward-thinking we
move some of the stuff back
to Shanghai where we can get a
cheaper, better, blah blah...
That's one very likely sort of thing.
Also what the next round
of innovation is gonna be,
nobody knows, but yes people do know.
There's no specific thing
but energy, technology,
everyone knows that.
Well, we're not doing very well.
I mean every one of our
politicians explains
that we are a world leader,
we are always a world leader, we're not.
We're a pathetic follower.
We certainly don't have
much of an installed base,
we're not leaders in making this stuff,
we have a lot of very
promising laboratory work.
So do other people.
And the disconnect between laboratory work
and then you got to make it.
Whereas in internet technology,
there's no making it.
You can sell one product
or a hundred million,
it's the same, the costs are the same.
To produce one more copy of our software,
and you can automate the click,
you don't have to actually click.
Whereas to make solar
panels, you got to make them
and so forth.
Windmills, titles, whatever, (mumbles).
So no, we could be
but thus far we're not.
Will we be?
We could, I think it's
entirely a political question.
After that, I see every reason for
a certain amount of choking
heartbreaking pessimism.
- And this takes us full circle
back to your career in a
way and where you started,
because you told us well, I got interested
in political economy,
the interface between
politics and economics.
And what you're now telling
us through the analysis
in this book is that we
have to think differently
about the relation of
the state to the economy
in this new global context,
which we have partly created.
And if we don't, we're
going to be up a creek
because for example in energy technology,
the state is going to have to
do something along the lines
of what the Pentagon
did during the Cold War
in terms of setting the
stage for us moving forward.
- Yeah.
- And my sense is that
well, you just said it
but let's explore this.
What do you think will make us adapt
to this very different
view of the relationship
of the state to the economy?
'Cause the state has to be,
you say we can't do
planning and we won't do it
because it's a concept that
goes against our culture
and our institute, then what do we do,
to prepare us for this
world which we've created
and which we're now losing in?
- Do you have an easier question?
(Harry laughs)
We did a little bit of
planning, maybe enough.
As you said, we had this
thing called the Pentagon
and the nice thing about the Pentagon
was it was like brackets
in economic thinking.
You could think up to
the bracket and after,
but you're not allowed to think
about what's going on there.
It's off the table for economic thinking.
And a lot of it was just a huge waste,
I mean a colossal waste.
Some of it was vital to save
ourselves and the world,
and some of it, a small part
was America's industrial policy.
We didn't call it industrial
policy, picking winners.
We called it military--
- And this would be through--
- Jet planes for instance.
Commercial jet planes.
I remember the Boeing 707 was the...
Well, some of the Europeans used to argue
that the Boeing 707
was the K-135 military
tanker with windows.
And it really was, and it came
down the same assembly line
using the same fantastic machine tools
that could scope the Brancusi statue
in 12 dimensional space,
with the big jet engines
that had been developed
at huge cost in technology
and needed special metallurgy.
That gave us the
undisputed lead in the sky.
Satellite technology, do you
know a guy in Silicon Valley
who could put that up?
No, you can't do those in a garage.
A whole raft, the internet,
its maiden name as you will
remember was the DARPA net.
The good folks at DARPA said,
"What happened if the
Russkies nuke Chicago?
"We have to communicate."
They created a communication
system with no central node
or nodes and then it grew.
Computing, everyone
remembers the first computers
filled a room 10 times the size
of this and needed 50 people
to change the bulbs.
Who on God's earth would
buy one of these babies?
And that is the seed corn
of the round of innovation
that propelled our
economy for a long time.
It was the government picking winners.
It's not so hard to pick winners if you...
Some of these things, it's in that
which particular model
is a different story,
but getting things going
in that direction, yeah.
- Now, let's talk a little
about the Obama administration
in its first year, because he was elected
with a lot of hope about the
way he could change things.
And if we look at, his policy--
- [Stephen] I disagree with you.
- Oh, okay.
- He was elected less with
hope than with desperation.
What W. Bush and company
had done to smash,
to destroy this great country
and they did a hell of a job.
I mean you name the
dimension from the big one,
our role as the leader of the world,
we became somehow the
bad guy of the world.
Our role as rich, we ended
up with a beggar's bowl.
Our role is let them see
us, they saw new audience,
they saw epigraph.
Even the small things like
environment so to speak,
whatever it was, they destroyed it.
Through a combination of
ideology and pure cynicism.
So yeah, people turned
to this guy, please,
they gave him a Nobel
Prize for being alive.
- And being elected.
- For replacing that.
Please, please bring us
back the United States
we've known and loved.
The world needs the United States.
Not sure it's gonna get it.
- So if he, let's accept
what you're saying,
if he was elected out of desperation,
are we seeing evidence that he can move us
in the area of recognizing
some of the problems
that you've identified?
And in particular, the
changing role of the state
as it deals with this series of problems.
And this seems to be very
much related to the way
the banks are treated basically,
in light of the disaster that came about
in last year's financial crisis.
Because in a way, what
you're telling us is
that the banking sector
grew from 14% to 21%
and with that came a lot of
power to influence elections
and campaigns and so on.
Is that gonna change and what
will it take to change that?
It would seem that there
are two problems here.
One is preparing for this
future that is upon us
with the development
of the sovereign funds
where the state has to
play a greater role.
But the other is to putting the
banking sector in its place.
- I think you've got it right.
So why ask me? I don't know.
Look, we did this health care reform.
I cannot explain it to myself,
let alone to a student.
It's ju-jitsu a bit, it's a...
Why is it so complicated?
Remember there are other
countries on earth.
All the others have health care systems
that work better than ours,
all the rich countries, okay?
I'm not talking about Bangladesh.
Switzerland, that has private guys.
France that has both
and they all have better
numbers at much less cost,
much less cost.
We are doing this health
reform in order to preserve
the health insurance
companies and a few other.
We are doing this banking
reform, maybe bailout reform
in order to preserve...
Why preserve it?
I'm perhaps too foolish
and I don't understand.
It's my ignorance, why I have to preserve
the health insurers that
gobble up everything,
make everybody's life a misery.
If you've ever had, it's a
medical, it's a nightmare.
While you're crying your heart out,
you have to deal with these
refusal and change of service
and your doctor is not in this
group and he's not in that.
It is ridiculous, it is
painful, it is wasteful.
Well gee, everybody in
the country knows that,
so why don't we change it?
Well, maybe we're, when
you watch countries
who get into trouble,
it's always political.
The cause of the bad economy is political.
- And that I guess is what the economists
are afraid to admit
or don't have the analytic
skills to admit it?
- It's outside of their domain,
that's the next office over there.
We don't do that, we don't do political.
But if we got the political house in order
then the economic stuff could,
there's a lot of really good work.
But right now, the problem is
rooted in the political side.
- And I think you're
suggesting that the paradigm,
the neoliberal paradigm
has collapsed but that
may not be recognized.
'Cause one of the refreshing
things about your book,
I thought was that it linked this collapse
to choices that were
made several decades ago
by both parties.
And we're really not ready to admit that.
- I think you're quite correct.
I think we're gonna...
The patient is not dead.
We've got him out of intensive care,
he's still in the room,
they're running us (mumbles).
We're gonna have a, it seems to me,
another go at it.
- At the neoliberal--
- Look what's going in the
finance sector, back to go,
what's going on in the
health sector, back to go.
Well, that's two big hunks of everything.
So we seem unable.
Now, you think what can
change is it's a crisis?
And they're not gonna
change it because you or I
or even the president
says hey, we really have
to change this.
So a crisis and...
Maybe they rate, what
we may come to think of
the tragedy of Obama is he
was elected a year too early.
Remember Roosevelt was elected
in '32 election, November.
He took office, was it March?
The crisis starts in '29.
By the time the election came
around, it was a disaster
and by the time he kept,
and even Hoover said,
"You want to work with me?"
No, no.
It really was a disaster.
So Mr. Roosevelt,
do whatever you want, please do something.
Obama came in, it hadn't
gotten bad enough.
- And the other thing
to further your point
is that enough was done
to make it not bad enough
for the world that Roosevelt inherited.
- So I'm not sure we're
gonna make any real changes.
And if we don't of course,
we're even worse trouble,
I think goes without saying.
- On that pes--
- Yes, there we go.
No, it's economics, they're dismal.
- No, dismal sign.
So I want to thank you
for being our guest, Steve
and I want to recommend
very strongly your new book
which you wrote with Brad
DeLong, The End of Influence
because it is well written,
it's not a long book
but it really lays out
the crisis we're in.
But looking at it in
such a way that we see
the broad picture, so thank
you very much for the book.
And thank you very much
for being on our program.
- It was a pleasure.
- Thank you and thank you
very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(lively music)